E
WILL BE PAYING 90, MAYBE $100 A
BARREL FOR OIL, AND TONIGHT
THOSE MEAN TWEETS FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY ARE
LOOKING PRETTY GOOD RIGHT ABOUT
NOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE WORKED
AROUND-THE-CLOCK.
MIGHT NOT LIKE HIS STYLE, BUT HE
DID ADVANCE AMERICA'S INTERESTS
AT HOME.
AMERICA FIRST.
HE ALSO DID IT ABROAD.
HE FOUGHT HARD, HE KEPT HIS
PROMISES, AND AMERICA IN THE
WORLD PROSPERED.
AND BY THE WAY, PEOPLE FEARED
DONALD TRUMP AS PRESIDENT.
THEY BELIEVED IT WHEN HE SAID HE
WOULD OBLITERATE THEM LIKE HE
DID THE CALIPHATE, LIKE HE DID
SO MONEY, LOCATED BAGHDADI AND
ASSOCIATES AND THE AL QAEDA
LEADER IN YEMEN.
JOE BIDEN, HE'S BEING ROLLED BY
HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST PARTY AND
THEY CALL THE SHOTS.
HE ANSWERS TO THEM, HE DOES WHAT
THEY SAY.
IF THEY GET THEIR WAY, AMERICA
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME AGAIN.
HERE WITH MORE, FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE, MIKE POMPEO.
YOU KNOW, I'M WATCHING THE
ATTACKS COME IN, AND THEY SAY
THIS IS THE TRUMP PLAN.
I'VE ASKED YOU THIS QUESTION
BEFORE.
THE TRUMP PLAN, CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG, WAS PREDICATE AT
FIRST AND FOREMOST ON
OBLITERATING THE TALIBAN.
DONALD TRUMP SAID TO THE HEAD OF
THE TALIBAN IF WE GET AN
AGREEMENT AND YOU DON'T ABIDE BY
IT, I WILL LET YOU FINISH THE
CONVERSATION.
>> SEAN, IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
WE CERTAINLY SAID THAT AND THEN
WE EXECUTED IT WHEN THE TALIBAN
BEHAVED IN WAYS THAT WERE
INCONSISTENT WITH PROTECTING
AMERICA, OUR INTEREST IN
AFGHANISTAN OR ELSEWHERE.
WE CRUSH THEM, WE USED AMERICAN
POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
MODEL OF DETERRENCE WOULD WORK.
WE HAD A REAL PLAN ON HOW TO GET
OUR TROOPS DOWN TO THE LOWEST
LEVELS POSSIBLE.
WE KNEW THAT THERE WERE CERTAIN
SET OF CONDITIONS THAT HAD TO BE
MET, WE WERE WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO ACHIEVE THEM.
WE WENT FROM 15,000 TO ABOUT 27,
2800, AND WE KEPT ORDER, WE
DIDN'T HAVE A SINGLE AMERICAN
ATTACKED FROM FEBRUARY OF 2020
ON.
THAT WAS NOT BECAUSE OF A PIECE
OF PAPER, AND AGREEMENT, BUT
BECAUSE THEY FEARED OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, I'VE KNOWN
DONALD TRUMP FOR WELL OVER 25
YEARS.
I CAN SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY I DON'T
SEE ANY SCENARIO THAT YOU WOULD
EVER ABANDON AMERICANS BEHIND
ENEMY LINES.
WITH THAT HAVE EVER HAPPENED
WITH DONALD TRUMP AS PRESIDENT
AND U.S. SECRETARY OF STATE?
>> NO, SIR, IT'S UNIMAGINABLE,
SEAN, THAT WE WOULD HAVE
PERMITTED THIS TO HAPPEN.
WE WERE SERIOUS ABOUT PROTECTING
AMERICANS.
NOT ONLY ARE SOLDIERS, SAILORS,
AIRMEN'S, AND MARINES BUT OUR
DIPLOMATS, INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS
AT ALL THE OTHER AMERICANS WHO
WERE THERE WELL.
WE MADE REAL COMMITMENT TO THEM
AND WE SAID THIS IS HOW WE ARE
GOING TO DO THIS IN AN ORDERLY
WAY.
WE PROCEEDED ACROSS THAT PLAN,
THEY CAME IN AND RIPPED IT UP,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SET A POLITICAL
DEADLINE, AND ARBITRATE DEADLINE
AND HE DID SO WITH HIS MILITARY
LEADERS HAVING TOLD THEM IF YOU
GO BELOW 2500, 2700, THAT A
CALAMITY WILL ENSUE.
HE MADE THAT CHOICE, IT WAS
DEEPLY POLITICAL AND NOW AMERICA
IS PAYING THE PRICE FOR THIS.
>> Sean: AND DONALD TRUMP
WOULD HAVE KEPT BOGNER AIRBASE,
DONALD TRUMP TOLD
ME WHEN I INTERVIEWED HIM, THAT
HE WOULD IN FACT HAVE KEPT 2500
TROOPS ON THE GROUND AS THE
GENERALS NOW CLEARLY RECOMMENDED
JOE BIDEN LIED TO GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, BUT HE ALSO LIED
SAYING HE WOULDN'T ABANDON
AMERICANS.
DO YOU SEE ANY SCENARIO THAT IS
RELATIVELY SAFE WHERE WE CAN GET
OUR PEOPLE HOME SAFELY?
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN SAYS WE HAVE
ALL THE LEVERAGE.
I DON'T SEE IT.
>> YEAH, SEAN, WE GAVE UP ALL
HER LEVERAGE WHEN WE RAN OUT,
WHEN WE ABANDONED AND CREATED
THIS DEBACLE, WE NOT ONLY GAVE
OF OUR LEVERAGE, BUT 13 AMERICAN
LIVES AS WELL.
THERE ARE LOTS OF AMERICANS WERE
WORKING TO HELP GET THEIR FELLOW
COMRADES HOME FROM BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
I HEAR FROM FOLKS NEARLY EVERY
DAY, IF TRY TO HELP AS I CAN AS
WELL.
WE ARE FIGHTING OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE WORKING TO TRY AND WORK
AROUND AND GET ASSISTANCE FROM
OUR GOVERNMENT, NOT -- WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE FIGHTING
THEM IN THE WAY WE ARE.
I DON'T SEE THIS AT
ADMINISTRATION BEGINNING TO
CHANGE THAT POLICY.
I THINK THEY WANT TO WRITE THIS
OFTEN JUST TURN THE PAGE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LET
THAT HAPPEN, WE WILL ALL
REMEMBER.
>> Sean: HE USED THAT EXACT
PHRASE AT THE U.N.
HE HAS NOT MENTIONED THE PEOPLE
THAT HE ABANDONED AFGHANISTAN OR
THE ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF
AFGHANISTAN, IN 30 DAYS, HASN'T
TALKED ABOUT THEM ONE TIME.
TONY BLINKEN NOW, THIS IS
RECENTLY, THERE ARE AMERICAN
GROUPS -- I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
ARE -- BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE RETIRED SPECIAL OPS FORCES,
RETIRED NAVY SEALs AND
GENEROUS AMERICANS THAT HAVE
CHARTERED AIRPLANES AND THAT ARE
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO GET
AMERICANS HOME.
I WANT EVERY AMERICAN HOME.
I WANT EVERY GREEN CARD HOLDER
HOME.
I WANT THEIR FAMILIES HOME, THE
FAMILIES THAT WE PROMISED TO GET
THE HELL OUT OF THERE.
HERE'S MY QUESTION,
TONY BLINKEN, YOU HAD HIS JOB,
IS NOW TAKING -- THING YOU CAN'T
TAKE THE CHARTER PLANE EVEN IF
THERE'S AMERICANS ON IT, YOU
CAN'T LAND IN THE U.S. AND IF
YOU GET A THIRD COUNTRY PARTY TO
ACCEPT YOUR CHARTER, THEY WILL
NEED APPROVAL AND IT WILL NOT BE
FORTHCOMING.
CAN YOU GIVE ME ANY RATIONAL
EXPO NATION FOR THAT POLICY?
BECAUSE THAT MAKES ZERO SENSE TO
ME.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS REFERENCING
EARLIER.
WE HAVE OUR OWN GOVERNMENT
OPPOSING PRIVATE CITIZENS TRYING
TO GET HOME.
THIS IS CRAZY, THERE'S NO
RATIONALE.
WEIGHT GOT WILLING -- PEOPLE
WILLING TO TAKE THEIR OWN
LIFE -- RISK THEIR OWN LIVES TO
GET THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS HOME.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD BE
CALLING THEM TO BE THINKING
THEM, NOT TELLING YOU CAN'T
BRING AN AIRCRAFT.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE
PREPARED TO ASSIST US,
ULTIMATELY ONWARD TO THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION IN OUR GOVERNMENT IS
OPPOSING THAT TODAY.
IT IS ON EXPENDABLE TO ME, SEAN.
>> Sean: WISTER SECRETARY, I
SAY THIS IS A FRIEND OF YOURS
FOR A LOT OF YEARS.
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR FROM